I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
let's start our new life
[Music]
does anyone in Andalusia ever just say
stuff not if we can help it foreign
this world feels very different is it
sometimes easier to live in andalasia
well I wouldn't say easier we have
dragons and ogre rebellions last year
the entire kingdom was trapped in a
giant whale oh this is not a magic land
it is a land far far away from my
friends I'm so late I'm a commuter now
you're riding this train over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and then you die
as you can see Giselle everyone has
their place once you've found where you
fit Monroeville can be
whatever you wish I wish for a fairy
tale life
happily ever after it's not always that
easy
so hi and my dress is so low Jumping
Jelly sticks we got magic
[Music]
town is turning into a fairy tale
but it's all gone terribly wrong I'm the
last stroke of midnight
nothing will be as it was before
an evil cat I'm not an evil cat I'm not
an evil cat
what is going on you need to remember
your place here stepmother please
[Music]
Giselle is it under a curse we have to
stop this or everything and Elation will
die there's no one wishing your wish now
Giselle come on time to be heroes
you know there's only room for one
villain in this town
you're hilarious
delusional but hilarious